okay the fourth and final skillset that
I want people to take away from this
rambling is how to influence people
influence whether you I'll call it
persuasion or influence it's really
similar to similar to copywriting but
this one's a little bit more
psychological but it's similar and what
most people don't realize is how to get
people to do what you want them to do or
how to influence them to think how you
think and that sounds evil but that's
not how I mean it I mean you could use
it for evil ways I mean the stuff that
you convince people to give to a
non-profit or you convince people of
certain morals or why something's bad
and something's good it's the same stuff
that you can use to get people to do a
lot of really bad things and so this is
definitely a scary skill set to learn
but if you but the thing is is that
people are like animals I mean in the
same way that if you show a dog food
you know what's that Pavle Pavlovian
experiment where you you show dog food
and you ring a bell so the dog starts
associating the Bell with the food and
so whenever you ring the bell he starts
slobbering people are the same way you
can there's all these little tricks that
you can do to get people to say yes to
certain things or get them to buy into
certain things more so for example if
I'm a politician and I want to put a
huge billboard in your front yard the
likelihood that I of me just knocking on
your door and asking to put this big
billboard in yards in your yard the
likelihood of you saying yes is pretty
low but if I go in there and I say hey
can I put this small little sticker on
your window and you and the likelihood
of you saying yes so that is quite high
now if I go back a week later and ask
you to put this big billboard in your
front yard the likelihood then that
you're gonna say yes is a lot higher
than had I not asked you to put that
small sticker because you're already
bought in and there's about eight or
nine principles just like this of
getting you to buy anything so another
one's the rule reciprocity and so what
that means is let's say that I I go out
or let's say that you go out of town and
you
I'm your neighbor and you asked me to
check your mail for you when I'm gone
and I say yeah sure no problem I'll
check your mail you I've just done a
favor for you now you owe me a favor
and this is how humans work we all we
work on favors and so now let's say next
week I go hey look I watch I I checked
your mail last week can I borrow your
car for a day the likelihood that you're
gonna say yes is actually a lot higher
because I've already done you a favor
and so the interesting thing about the
rule reciprocity is that people pay it
back disproportionately meaning I can do
a really small favor for someone and
then I can ask them to do a much bigger
favor and shockingly so a lot of times
they'll say yes and so there's about
eight or nine of these principles that
are incredibly effective for influencing
people another example I've used this
before I wanted to go I went and bought
a motorcycle for a guy for three grand
or he was asked him three grand for and
I thought it was I thought yeah I'd be
willing to pay about 2,200 bucks for
this and so I went and bought a can of
coke I bought two of them and when I
showed up to the place I opened up one I
start drinking I go hey man uh you
thirsty they you want a coke I was just
down the street and I bought one and I
thought maybe you don't want to he
opened it up he starts drinking it and I
go cool motorcycle I'll give you twenty
two but he goes huh everyone's been
offering me that I'm not gonna do it
but you seem like a nice guy I'll do it
fine and so I don't know if the coke was
the reason but that's just an example of
there's all these little tiny things
that if you do them effectively they
kind of add up to be pretty effective
and so to learn these things there's
this great book by Robert Chow Dini
called influence if you just google
influence book you'll see it seems
Robert Chow Dini read that it's it's
that book changed my life and the second
one which is pretty famous a lot of
people know it it's called how to win
friends and influence people that book I
think that book is one of the
best-selling books of all time the
best-selling non-fiction books of all
time it was written in the 1930s 1920s
it's still 100 percent effective so go
and read those two books and I and I
think that if you learn how to
fluence people it's really really really
effective and it will shock you now like
I was a nerd in high school and I liked
women and so I was always just like any
other kid I wanted to go meet girls
I remember reading this book as a kid I
was like I want them to like me how do I
do that
and so I read this book and I would
apply this stuff to meet girls and it
worked I am married to an amazing woman
and she was way out of my league when I
first met her and she still is out of my
league and I remember I use some of
these things when I met her and it
helped me kind of get my foot in the
door it's so this stuff will help you
make money and will help you start a
company it will help you balance your
emotions or it will help you meet your
your future spouse it's incredibly
effective and so
[Music]
you